il eut une époque où boîtes en plastique
sacs à main panier nm cartable n'était
pas monnaie courante à la ligne 1 les
contenants appelé vannes sac ou encore
bertel était de formes différentes mais
avaient pour la plupart la même texture
ils étaient fabriqués à partir des
feuilles de va quoi le va quoi pandanus
utilise est une hydre auckland allure
très particulière en forme de parasol
avec des racines aériennes
ce n'est pas un panier mais une
monocotylédones arborescentes de la
famille dépens d'un ac
le varois peut atteindre sept mètres de
hauteur
c'est un arbre originaire des rivages de
l'océan indien à l'aller chez moi au
delà
chez josy bien menace at war ou un petit
peu au mit travail on me fait un petit
peu move à coire et ateliers nous sommes
chez josy collec à saint-philippe dans
le sud sauvage
là où ils habitent et nous fait visiter
son atelier et sa pièce d'exposition
jésus très chaque jour avec sa soeur
j'ai si leur histoire avec le vacoa
remonte à leurs enfants ce travail va
quoi depuis que nous ils étaient
marmaille nue partent avec notre maman
chez de bakwa
travail et une physique bertel tendu
donner un petit coup de main à notre
maman tout le temps que nous l'a agrandi
et puis après pas maintenant nous a
appris à faire nous mêmes et si
aujourd'hui les traceurs de vagues fois
fabrique surtout pour vendre autrefois
chaque famille tressé pour leur propre
usage domestique
port-vendres même novedia peut-être pas
parce qu'il ne faisait pas vraiment des
choses qui vendent et lui faisait pour
pour nous pour la maison pour la tati
pour le tonton pour ce qu il faisait
part mais diaconu faisait vraiment comme
maintenant nufer nous nom ne faisait pas
ça longtemps comme objet nu faisait
longtemps nous c'était la bea telle
attente la saisie pouquoi ne peux dormir
son épée de bois rond et c est chaud
après quoi nous faisait encore avec la
tente pour aller en et le manger dedans
tout ce qui était utile pour ce travail
pas de contrainte particulière à part
faire attention aux épines et respecter
certaines règles de préparation de la
matière première
jeudi nous explique le cheminement du
wacq war de l'arbre à l'objet d'un
travail commencé par prendre un point
d'un couteau déjà parce qu'il faut aller
chercher la paille que ce soit la paille
ou va coiffer à professer chez pour que
ce soit un peu plus grand pour que pour
des puisse travailler après il faut des
tours et le varois enlever les feuilles
ils enlèvent des feuilles nous tiens les
épines après effectué fait angela meade
d'après la grandeur que nous nous devons
travailler est prévenu mais c'est chez
faut sécher il faut attendre au moins on
va dire deux trois jours et une fois
séchées bon bah après ben maintenant
comme on aime soit on fait des congrès
salle et des tissages soit détresse et
puis après bon travail stressés leva
quoi elle savoir presque inné chez les
habitants du sud de l'île un trésor qui
risque de disparaître si les jeunes ne
prennent pas la relève
nous on arrive quand même un certain âge
qu'eux on est on va dire plus sur la fin
que l'oeuf le début de la vie c'est
dommage que de ne pas faire quelque
chose de sérieux pour que les jeunes
puissent prendre ça en main pour pouvoir
que la tradition reste quand même à la
réunion
c'est ce sera vraiment un bon point pour
la bon peu pour la réunion que josie et
sa soeur g6 ne cesse de mettre en avant
tant bien que mal
les temps